It turns out that one of the central requirements of a good relationship...
...is a degree of affection for ourselves,...
...built up over the years, largely in childhood.
We need a legacy of being deserving of love...
...in order not to respond very obtusely to the affections granted to us by adult partners.
Without a decent amount of self-love,...
...the love of another person will always prove sickening and misguided...
...and we will self-destructively, though unconsciously,...
...set out to repel or disappoint it.
It will simply feel more normal and therefore comfortable...
...to be disliked or ignored when that is mostly what we have known.
If we are not wholly convinced of our own lovability,...
...receiving affection can appear like being bestowed a prize...
...for an accomplishment we don't feel we ever earned.
People unfortunate enough to fall in love with self-hating types...
...must brace themselves for the recriminations due to false flatterers.